Ya estamos muy acostumbrados
a utilizar los operadores
de suma, de resta, de multiplicación y de división,
incluso hasta tenemos otros
símbolos para estos dos.
Pero lo que quiero hacer en este video,
es algo mucho más divertido.
Quiero que aprendamos a definir
nuestros propios operadores.
Esto nos va a ayudar a ver lo
amplio que son las matemáticas
y en un sentido un poco más práctico,
nos va a ayudar a resolver problemas,
que vienen en algunos exámenes estandarizados.
Pero vaya, incluso estos problemas
que vienen en los exámenes estandarizados,
tienen detrás una idea de...
de pues que veamos que estos cuatro
no son los únicos operadores,
sino que en realidad
podemos definir muchos más.
Entonces déjame empezar con este ejemplo.
Voy a definir "x"
diamante "y"...
"x" diamante "y"
como "5x"...
"5x" menos "y",
entonces la idea es que esto,
es más o menos como una función,
solo que ahora le vamos a meter
dos valores "x" y "y",
y de regreso nos va a dar la expresión
"5x" menos "y".
Como... como es una función que depende
de dos valores, se conoce como un operador,
entonces con esta definición,
imagínate que nos piden determinar cuánto es 7...
7 diamante 11...
diamante 11.
Bueno, entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es aquí cambiar todas las "x" por 7
y todas las "y" por 11,
entonces este 7 va para acá,
este 11 va para acá,
entonces nos quedaría, 5 por 7...
déjame ponerlo con color naranja...
del 7,
5 por 7 menos "y" y "y" vale 11.
Entonces sería menos, menos 11.
Muy bien y con esto ya podemos hacer las operaciones, 5 por 7 es 35 y 35...
bueno lo voy a hacer poco a poco... es 35...
es 35..
¡ay! eso quedó un poco feo, deja
pongo el 5 más bonito.
Y a eso tenemos que restar 11,
35 menos 11 es igual a 24,
y por lo tanto, 7 diamante "y" es igual a 24,
simplemente sustituimos y realizamos las operaciones.
Déjame hacer otro ejemplo aquí a la derecha,
vamos a poner...
vamos a definir la operación...
"a"... "a" estrella "b"...
"a" estrellla "b".
Muy bien, entonces, "a" estrella "b"
va a ser igual a "a"
entre "a" más "b".
Ahorita, lo estoy inventando si,
en realidad hay mucha flexibilidad, podemos,
pudimos haber dicho que esto era pues casi cualquier cosa.
Voy a ponerle que es "a" entre "a"más "b".
Entonces imagínate que ahora
nos piden determinar 5...
5 estrella 6...
5 estrella...
estrella...
lo voy a poner también con verde...
5 estrella 6.
Muy bien, entonces
¿esto a qué sería igual?
Pues "a" vale 5 y "b" vale 6, simplemente
sustituimos 5 en cada lugar donde haya una "a"
y 6 en cada lugar donde haya una "b".
Entonces nos quedaría, 5 dividido...
dividido entre 5...
5 más 6
y realizamos las operaciones,
aquí está muy sencillito,
arriba nos queda 5 y abajo nos queda 11,
5 más 6 es 11
y por lo tanto 5 estrellita 6 es cinco onceavos.
Muy bien, ahora,
también podemos componer ambas operaciones.
Pero al componerlas tenemos que utilizar paréntesis, porque todavía no hemos decidido
si primero va la operación diamante,
o si primero va la operación estrella.
Déjame poner un ejemplo
para ver a qué me refiero,
imagínate que nos piden determinar,
cuál es el valor, no sé, de -1...
-1...
diamante...
y aquí voy a poner el paréntesis que te digo...
0...
estrella...
5,
una vez más, el paréntesis es importante
porque no conocemos el orden de las operaciones,
aquí arriba sabemos que la multiplicación
va antes que la suma,
pero aquí abajo no sabemos si estrella
va antes que diamante.
Bueno,
entonces,
vamos a realizar esta operación, vale,
esta composición de operaciones.
Como... como aquí hay un paréntesis
vamos a empezar con eso de ahí,
vamos a hacer primero 0 estrella 5,
entonces vamos a la definición de estrella,
"a" es 0, "b" es 5,
nos quedaría,
0 entre 0 más 5.
Muy bien, 0 entre cualquier cosa que no sea 0 es 0,
entonces esto de aquí es 0.
Y por lo tanto ahora, esta expresión es igual...
es igual a -1 diamante...
diamante 0...
diamante 0.
Muy bien, ahora sí, como ya tenemos una cosa en términos de la operación diamante, nos vamos para acá,
"x" vale -1, "y" vale 0,
entonces nos quedaría 5 por "x",
5 por -1
y a eso tenemos que restarle, 0.
5 por -1 es -5,
-5
y bueno restar 0 no es hacer nada,
entonces nos queda -5.
Y por lo tanto, este es el resultado
de nuestra composición de operaciones, vale.
Bueno, la idea general es que te sientas
cómodo definiendo nuevos operadores,
no hay que espantarse si de repente
te encuentres un diamante por ahí,
si te dan la definición de diamante, entonces
sabes exactamente que hacer para evaluarlo,
simplemente sustitutyes los valores
en el orden correspondiente, vale.
Bueno, estos son algunos ejemplos sencillos,
déjame hacer uno un poco más raro,
porque puedes ver cosas más extrañas.
Aunque no entren tanto en el mundo de los operadores, es más o menos la misma idea.
Imagínate que de repente alguien decide definir
esta cosa extraña que es el diamante mayor.
Aquí voy a poner un diamante grandote,
o el gran diamante,
vamos a llamarle el gran diamante.
Entonces,
imagínate que alguien te define gran diamante,
para cuatro números
"a", "b", "c" y "d",
y te dicen ¿sabes qué?
gran diamante de "a", "b", "c", "d",
es igual a "ad" menos "b"
dividido entre "c",
va.
Entonces, otra vez no hay que espantarse,
esto es simplemente una definición
y justo esta igualdad nos dice como podemos
tratar a diamante mayor, al gran diamante.
Entonces, ahora, pues esa misma persona,
te podría pedir que encontraras
el valor de gran diamante...
gran diamante...
de no sé, déjame ponerle por aquí unos
números... de
-1, 5, 3 y 2,
por decir algo.
Entonces, simplemente lo que hay que hacer es ver
cuál es el valor de cada uno de estos números, a que...
a que letra corresponden y sustituir.
Para no hacerme bolas,
déjame ponerle que este es "a",
este es "b", este
es "c" y este es "d",
y entonces ahora sí, con esto en mente,
tenemos que hacer, "a" por "d",
es decir, -1 por 2...
-1 por 2
y a eso tenemos que restarle "b",
o sea restarle 5
y luego tenemos que dividir...
tenemos que dividir entre "c",
aquí tenemos "c", que es 3.
¿Cuánto nos da?
-1 por 2 es -2,
-2 menos 5
entre 3...
y -2 menos 5 es igual a -7, por los tanto,
nos queda menos siete tercios, ok.
Entonces esto de aquí parecía muy espantoso al inicio,
había un gran diamante, pero no hay que preocuparse,
simplemente con la definición podemos trabajar
con gran diamante, vale.
Bueno, lo que te recomiendo ahorita
es jugar un poco
y de hecho, hacer tus propias operaciones,
diviértete un ratito,
haz tus propias operaciones
y ve que cosas interesantes puedes encontrar.